welcome to episode 24 of the michaela
peterson podcast
in this episode i spoke with dr michael
ruscho
michael rousseau is a doctor clinical
researcher and best-selling author
whose practical ideas on healing chronic
illness
have made him an influential voice in
functional and alternative medicine
his work has been published in
peer-reviewed medical journals and he
speaks at
integrative medical conferences across
the globe
dr ruscho also runs an influential
website and podcast at dr ruscio.com
in addition to his clinical practice
located in northern california
he specializes in gut health and the
microbiome
in this episode i hope we covered
commonly asked questions about those
topics we delved into probiotics a bit
and this was recorded a while ago so
i'll give you a quick
update on some of what we spoke about i
did end up trying
one of the probiotics he suggested i
still haven't been able to find any that
don't give me autoimmune symptoms
perhaps that will change in the future
but it hasn't as of yet probiotics are
still
out other than that everything else is
up to date in this episode
if you haven't checked out his book he
wrote a book called healthy gut healthy
you which is definitely worth reading
i do believe that the majority of
autoimmune and mental health issues
begin in the gut like hippocrates said
i do believe that's contributed to my
autoimmune and mood disorders
antibiotics mixed with a high sugar and
grain and other terrible foods diet
doesn't go well for humans i hope you
enjoy this episode
i think it's worth listening to for
everyone i'd like to thank
optimal carnivore for sponsoring this
episode optimal carnivore makes organ
supplements
if you are low in vitamin d might i
recommend their liver supplement
a lot of people are low in vitamin d and
given covid and flu season
it might be something worth
supplementing i talked about it a bit in
my episode with dr paul saladino
but there are vitamin benefits to organs
i generally eat liver
and bone marrow a few times a year i eat
bone marrow way more than a few times a
year
but liver in the winter when i crave it
and i don't tell people to force
down organs if they don't want to i do
recommend people getting a micronutrient
test
though through a natural path they give
you intracellular vitamin levels
and then supplementing if you need to
using organ supplements is a great way
to do that and if you take a
multivitamin already i would suggest
switching it over to something like what
optimal carnivore offers
way healthier and more bioavailable than
the usual multivitamins
they currently have a grass-fed organ
complex that contains nine different
organs
a grass-fed bone marrow and a grass-fed
liver product
visit amazon.com optimal carnivore and
use the code
michaela 10 to receive 10 percent off of
all of their products
if you need vitamins and you take a
multivitamin or are considering taking
one
this is what i would recommend instead
i'd also like to thank true local for
sponsoring this
episode you've been hearing a lot about
them from me but this is where i get my
meat in canada
although i also get a bit from
mennonites although the last thing i
bought from them were pepperoni sticks
which ended up
in an autoimmune flare-up so i'm
sticking solely with trulocal for now
if you go to truelocal.ca that's tru
local.ca you can make a box of whatever
meat cuts you want and they'll deliver
it to you flash frozen
i get their strip loins and lamb mainly
but their wild salmon is also amazing
and they have pork
and chicken and spiced meat use code mp
for free steaks and so they know where
you've come from
and keep sponsoring these episodes
that's truelocal.ca codemp
for locally and sustainably raised meat
i only
buy the best given the fact i only eat a
few foods i am very picky
and true local is the best i've had in
[Music]
canada
[Music]
hello dr roof show welcome to
my podcast and before we get started
your name is spelled r-u-s-c-i-o
how is it pronounced it's russia yeah
you you got right
about half the time people will say
russia which i get it looks like that
um and i don't really make a fuss one
way or the other but it is supposed to
be russia so thank you
okay okay great i have a hell of a time
with michaela actually because of the
k-h-a-i-l-a people get that wrong all
the time
um so would you be so kind as to provide
my audience with a bit of a background
about
who you are what your interests are and
yeah yeah um well you know i started off
uh in college with an interest in health
found my way onto the pre-med track
wanted to go into conventional medicine
and ended up when i was about 20
22 or 23 i went from being a college
athlete
and feeling pretty great all the time i
guess as most you know early 20
somethings do
and then fairly suddenly started having
insomnia
food reactive brain fog bouts of
depression fatigue
which was really quite different than
the experience of life that i was used
to having
and so i went to a few doctors i figured
well great you know this is what doctors
do
it's probably a little thing and these
are you know the things that doctors
tackle
so i saw a gp an internist
and endocrinologist because i was kind
of an overachiever and i was feeling
terribly so i wanted to make sure like
let's just cast a wide net
figure it out and none of them had
anything
for me they all said yeah you know you
have a healthy body composition
you're you know athletic you're probably
just stressed because of
yeah whatever you know insert platitude
here um
but the context was i loved what i was
doing wasn't under stress was eating
mostly organic meditating exercises
right so all those things were dialed in
so there was clearly another variable
that changed and this led me into
where i think many people end up which
is this
water of well conventional medicine
didn't help me what else
can i do and i found my way into
functional medicine i found a doctor who
um you know while i was doing some
independent training nutrition
and exercise there was this realm of
functional medicine which i never heard
of but i had figured well
at this point i have literally nothing
to lose and
i did a visit with this doctor he
proposed the idea that i may have a
parasite
and at first blush i thought he was
crazy because i didn't have any
digestive symptoms no gas no bloating no
diarrhea
no reflux anything like that but
i figured again i have nothing to lose
so i ended up doing some
assessment and i did actually have an
intestinal parasite quite a pathogenic
parasite actually which which i should
mention is pretty rare to have something
that bad but i did and
this was the root cause of all the
symptoms that i had
so i diverted my path to go into natural
medicine that's that's what i do now
um but and sorry to be kind of overly
proposed here but there is i feel a lot
of relevant context
as i got into the world of alternative
medicine
a lot of good but also a lot of just
hyperbole and dogma almost
the mirror image of what some may
criticize conventional medicine for
being a little bit you know never minded
not that i say i necessarily agree with
all those criticisms but those
criticisms are levied that
sometimes medical doctors are too
pission holding to the drug and
surgery model a lot of that was
happening in my observation and inverse
in the natural medicine community so
this has led me to really
question a lot of the canards that are
circulating in the field
because i've seen now that i've been in
practice almost 10 years
people really becoming damaged by we've
got to do
three thousand dollars worth of testing
to figure out
fish oil and a gluten-free diet right
which often ends up happening
um or no one can ever have any gluten or
you'll spontaneously combust it's it's
an evil for everyone all the time and if
you have one
fight yeah if you have one but you'll be
inflamed for six months
and i think that comes from a
well-intentioned place because maybe
some people aren't taking diet seriously
enough
sure get it but what i see is the people
who now have gone gluten-free low-fodmap
low oxalate low-lectin
and they've just recruited into this
corner of neurosis
where they're underweight they're
unhealthy they can't sleep they have no
energy
because they're afraid of everything
because they keep glomming on all these
different guru recommendations about
avoid x y and z
and then it leads to this kind of
runaway orthorexia
so what i'm trying to do now is really
pioneer this model
of yes let's be forward-thinking
open-minded
listen to patients when they come in
like me and say i have brain fog after i
eat food and the doctor says well
there's nothing wrong with your brain
you're not getting it something here is
clearly wrong so yes we're going to
listen and be progressive
but we're not going to just fall into
all the
of the conjecture that's just based upon
really questionable science in the
natural community we're going to try to
really be as discerning as we can
with the patient's best interest in mind
and so that's what what i'm
working on doing more so now is data
mining and publication so we can really
give people an offer up to them
here's what works here's how to get
there and we'll excise the dog
on both sides okay great this is going
to be a fantastic conversation
um i'm going to probably delve into a
bit of my experience because i think
it's relevant
um because i've had just a hell of a
time health-wise i'm trying to get my
symptoms under control and i had the
same experience i went to doctors i was
like these are all my symptoms
and mine were like my body's eating my
joints and
a lot of and they told me a lot of that
was like anxiety or stress
no the anxiety is part of the issue um
okay so where should we start first off
do you mind me asking what parasite it
is that you had
yeah i had amoeba histolytica which
as the name implies it's it's an amoeba
that
lyses tissue and it lyses into your
intestinal
wall and this kills people from
diarrheal death or dysenteric death in
throughput countries now here i mean
i don't believe it kills nearly anyone
because we have modern medicine
which hey that's a big you know plus on
the side of the scoresheet from modern
medicine yay like antibiotics for
certain things they do a really
fantastic job but what was interesting
in my case
and you could make the argument that if
someone is healthy enough
that a parasitic burden would not cause
them to be on the brink of death
but they'd be dysfunctional and there's
actually not to get too into the weeds
but
there's even this counter argument about
certain worms that
these worms may actually exert a
protective
anti-inflammatory impact on the gut um
the clinical sciences
you know the the inference suggests that
they
may be more beneficial than they've been
in in some of the clinical studies
therapy
yeah exactly exactly yeah so that's a
little i was gonna say can of worms no
pun intended but
that's a little bit of a can of worms
and probably not something that most
people
would even need to venture into but it
just serves a point that
you can be pretty healthy and then an
infection
can really kind of knock you off off the
track
okay okay interesting um so my
experience a bit
i i think that people who are forced
into
something like a carnivorous diet have
some sort of gut problem
problem going on or a variety of gut
problems going on and i experienced this
firsthand because i went i was okay
doing very very low carb um i was pretty
good actually and then i had a baby
which i know can change your microbiome
i've read the papers on that
and then i stopped being able to
tolerate plants everything was making me
ill
i switched over to the meat diet
switching over alleviated all my
symptoms and i ended up with a c
difficile infection
even though i hadn't been hospitalized i
hadn't taken antibiotics
and i don't think i'd really been
exposed because i was like a
stay-at-home mom
so i think i had that underlying
overgrowth and then
getting rid of all the carb-consuming
bacterias allowed it to overgrow
but i didn't have an option because all
the carbs were making me ill
so that took like a a long time to
figure out what that was because
i didn't know what c difficile was um so
for somebody like me and a lot of the
people who listen to this
podcast are pretty ill i'm assuming
we've got related problems
um i tried to repopulate like i tried a
lot
to try and figure out what to do
and i reacted to every probiotic i took
i fermented my own sauerkraut and tried
drinking little bits of the liquid
huge autoimmune flares and so where do
you
start if you're that screwed up
right well good question and and i i
totally
understand your frustration and this is
something that is a fairly large subset
of my practice which is patients who are
pretty sensitive and they've
they've been to a few different doctors
even in the alternative space
and there's a few different ways one one
can launch into this now
die is the foundation so assuming
someone's gone to
arguably the most restrictive diet which
would be carnivore
there's not a ton you really can change
there right yeah so typically if someone
comes in in that position
it's like okay there's other stuff going
on in the gut
now how do we push or pull the
microbiota or help with tissue healing
so that someone can start to expand
their diet because i agree with your
general contention which is
the carnivorous diet can be helpful but
i also
would like to put someone in a position
where they don't have to be carnivorous
maybe they choose to but at least they
have the
they're not forced into it yeah exactly
um
so probiotics actually is a good place
to start and and one of the things that
i've been discussing for
a couple years now is this more so
clinical observation that
really kind of pierces through a lot of
confusion regarding probiotics because
one of the problems i think
exists is there is a array of products
on the market and someone is just
inundated with
all these different products all the
marketing claims
and when you actually lay everything out
as we've done
in kind of a data table and say okay
let's look at all the studies
on probiotics let's say for ibs
now let's look at all the different
formulas that have been used in those
studies
okay turns out there's about eight
formulas that have mainly been used
amongst the
you know few hundred trials with
probiotics and ibs
and let's now compare side by side the
species or the strains that have been
used
there is a ton of overlap here from
formulator formula
what that can empower one to realize is
that
there's not really a special probiotic
for a given condition and i think the
challenge is that interesting
probiotics will be marketed
because the other the other influence
here is the market
influence which is this company puts
this money into developing a product and
they published a study
with it and that helps people and now
this is great marketing material
to sell our product which is that that
is fine and good but the problem is
when there's not this you know
overarching
you know body i guess or or the running
of those marketing claims
through a clinician what you have is
this just pandemonium
where there have been about 500 clinical
trials
let's say with and we'll get to this in
a second but you can pretty much
organize
all probiotics down into one of three
different
categorical types so with the with the
first type
the one that's been most studied in ibs
it's it's a blend of lactobacillus and
bifidobacterium strains
that's what i was referring to in the
data table and so
it gets really confusing because all
people see is the the vying marketing
claims for why this probiotic is good or
that probiotic is good
but no one's kind of zooming way out and
saying there is a ton of
overlap in terms of the different
species that have been used
people may claim well there's a certain
strain that we have to use we just
recently did this we went we added
another column and this is a pain in the
butt to do so i do not ever forget this
and we looked at the strains that have
been used and
pretty much every study has used a
different strain
in the different the formulas all have
different strains you would think well
if there was a certain strain that was
so important you would see
commonality from formula to formula to
formula to formula
with the strains what you see more often
is the strains are different
so this shoots a major hole in the
hypothesis
that there is one mixture of
either species or strains for a given
condition
and the good news there is that wow it
tells us that
different probiotics can exert a
beneficial influence
and then when we zoom way out and we see
the structure of there's these different
categorical types
mainly the formulas that have been
studied are a predominant blend of
lactobacillus and bifidobacterium this
is what i term
category one or a lacto-bifido blend a
saccharomyces polarity which is a
healthy fungus
yeah or these newer soil-based or
sport-forming
probiotics which are typically various
bacillus
species bacillus clausius bacillus
lesion formus
then what we can do is look at this
almost like
a a stool that one would sit on is the
analogy that i use
and ideally we want to have three legs
of support
underneath that stool to support balance
in the gut ecosystem
but by breaking them down into the three
what we can do is help personalize the
protocol to someone who may have
reactions
it is fairly rare for someone not to
tolerate
any one of the three categorical types
but in a highly sensitive patient
population
they may not tolerate a lactobifidol
blend probiotic
but what they end up doing is they hear
about one lactobio probiotic
and they try it and then on a podcast a
month later
they hear about a different
lactobidoprobiotic try that one
and also have a negative reaction they
end up in this merry-go-round because
they don't understand i seem to have a
negative reaction to this category
type so i'll try one or two quality
formulas if i still have a negative
reaction with both of those
i'll move on to type two and then on to
type three and most people even the most
sensitive
can usually tolerate at least one of
those three types
okay that's really interesting because
my experiences with um
lacto and buffetto um i'm sure
pretty much like i and i was considering
getting sporobiotics to try them one of
my friends had a good experience with
them i was like man
it's different maybe that'll work um i
just haven't gone into it
so so theoretically for a very sensitive
person um
and this is kind of what i've been
basing my kind of health experience on
is
heal the gut um and
theoretically i think from what i've
seen
theoretically limiting your diet to
something restricted like the carnivore
diet can
aid in healing the gut repopulate it
like i think one of the reasons i was
reacting was because i take these
probiotics and i'm worried they were
just
getting into my body right i don't know
how damaged my gut was but i'm assuming
pretty damaged
um so then repopulate and then
theoretically you should be able to
reintroduce
certain foods slowly with maybe
no reaction limited to no reaction
yep so um generally agree but but
there's a couple of things there you
know now that we're going to have a more
nuanced conversation i think we can we
can kind of unpack
um the the repopulating bit
it it seems that
a fair number of probiotics don't
actually take up residence yeah they're
transient right
they're trans but they still do have a
transient benefit they've been shown to
be able to
attenuate an overzealous immune response
reduce
leaky gut and then the other thing that
i think is really
underappreciated about probiotics is
they exert
pretty powerful antibacterial
anti-fungal and anti-parasitic activity
in fact some studies have even shown
that probiotics can be as effective as
antibiotics or as effective as
antifungal drugs now disclaimer
doesn't mean if you have a serious
condition that requires an antibiotic
quickly that you should just take a
probiotic blindly because i just said
that right but
you know clearly in gi we have studies
documenting
that if you have let's say small
intestinal bacterial overgrowth sibo
18 clinical trials have been summarized
in a meta-analysis
finding that probiotics can ameliorate
sibo
so this is something i think is
underappreciated and then this ties into
your other point about
having the reaction and i'm assuming you
navigated this correctly but i think
it's just important
to draw the distinction there there is
an important clarification
between a temporary adjustment reaction
or an intolerance reaction an adjustment
reaction usually abates by day five or
so and kind of rolls on and rolls off
but a intolerance reaction is kind of
flat lined and never gets any better
even once you get
past a week yeah that's definitely
important to um
to mention i know people who go to the
carnivore diet and try and reintroduce
carbs
even the safer ones sometimes have that
initial spike and freak out
and it is you have to wait for the
longer period to make sure that
you're actually not tolerating this um
okay i'm going to get your thoughts on
something that i wanted to
well talk to somebody about um this c
diff infection i had
got worse and worse and worse and it was
not fixable
and i tried antibiotics and it didn't
work and i went to you're probably
familiar with the tameout clinic
we had them on our podcast maybe about a
year ago oh cool
so i i went there and i did ten
treatments um because
okay so and for people listening they do
um fecal microbiota
transplants um into the colon right
so they isolate your the bacteria from
like healthy donor
donors and then stick it up your bum
basically
so i did ten sessions of that um
and nothing happened at all there was
one like one of those days i felt
better emotionally and i don't think
that was placebo and that was it and i
went back home and my c diff was just
horrible and at one point in the summer
about a year and a half ago i thought i
would have to be
hospitalized because i was getting
cramping just from drinking water
and i was like i can't drink anything
now right and so i did some research and
i came across a study where they took
fecal microbiota transplants
double encapsulated it and swallowed it
and
i did their protocol over a period of
three days
um which was horrifying because i had no
idea what was going to happen
and it was a scary thing to do and my c
difficile was gone
the day after i took the first bout of
it
so i haven't sorry just one one quick
clarification
how is the c diff being tested uh
through my medical doctor
still stannis is still testing expansion
yeah yeah um
and anyway it went away the next day so
i figured the c diff overgrowth was
actually in the small intestine instead
of the colon
um and i didn't have any negative effect
to that
like i had no probiotic negative effect
which was
shocking to me right um so
people had questions about the whole c
diff thing so i wanted to bring that up
but um small intestinal bacterial
overgrowth
is theoretically an overgrowth and i've
read a lot that you're not supposed to
take probiotics because you're going to
be increasing the amount of
yeah yeah right so
um what do you think is this it's a
shining example of where
there's a clear answer in the scientific
literature
yet for some reason this and i don't
think anyone who is saying this has bad
intentions
and i know some of the clinicians who
have made this recommendation and
they're great people
with contentions but this is a case
where
i think a few thought leaders maybe had
a initial experience probably with a
really really
sensitive subset of patients who reacted
to probiotics and then they made this
proclamation
that well in theory there's too much
bacteria so we add bacteria
and therefore this is probably why i'm
seeing this clinical observation
and then this led to this kind of
runaway narrative
and runaway nocebo effect and
unfortunately that message still kind of
really permeates the internet even
though again having 18 clinical trials
summarizing the meta-analysis is the
pinnacle of scientific evidence now the
the
retort that will be well i see a
sensitive patient group
so do i like um that's that's i think
that's a scapegoat and we really need to
all confront that and do a better job
with that
because it's really unfortunate when
a patient waits for a term to be seen in
my office
who has sibo who is suffering who's
never gone on probiotics because of what
you just
outlined and we put them on probiotics
in fact we've we've
published video case studies at least
two of these on our website
like some um phyllis paleo fodmap for a
year and a half
and have been on a couple different
probiotics historically never saw much
results
positive prior sibo breath test
and then we put her on the the three
probiotic protocol
and in two months she's feeling better
than she's felt in over a year and a
half
and that's that's not a rare observation
and now it's not to say that probiotics
are a cure-all or they work for everyone
but like we outlined there is that
ability to personalize the protocol
to the individual um so
yeah i think it's really unfortunate
that this that this um
false belief circulates on the internet
understand where it comes from it's a
totally
understandable inference to draw based
upon well
you know why would you put probiotics
into a situation of overgrowth
but the answer to that is because
probiotics
actually exert antibacterial antifungal
anti-parasitic effect
and oh by the way we've studied this in
18 clinical trials and the data are
pretty
conclusive that they help people again
the problem there is
some sibo patients are sensitive and
more prone to react so there's a chance
they may react to one of the three
probiotics
and then when they do clinicians go oh
see this is why we can't use probiotics
and this is kind of this
confirmation bias instead of working
with the patient
to personalize the protocol of the
individual and that can be so huge
because you can save people from having
to go to
kind of the next level of therapeutic
intervention which may be either an
antibiotic like rifaximin
or an herbal equivalent like oregano or
what have you i'm not to say those are
bad
but i'd much rather have someone on a
probiotic than on
those antimicrobial agents okay okay
that's interesting um
so yeah there are herbal remedies that
are just as effective as taking
antibiotics and
what you're saying is that's not it
necessarily safer
and that it might be safer to try and
add in bacteria that
might even out overgrowths rather than
wiping things out
yeah i mean it's certainly the first
the first position on so in in healthy
good healthy i lay out kind of this this
algorithm for people to follow because i
i wrote that book
to give people a step-by-step guide for
improving their gut health and
the foundational aspect is diet and
there's a few different ways that you
can go and the most rich it would be
carnivore
and then your second step is probiotics
and then your third step essentially is
antimicrobials
and to kind of zoom way out to give
people the overview
i think the the problem that people face
is they're looking for one
intervention to fix everything and for
someone who is
pretty healthy with just minor
imbalances that will work
right they'll have that huge response
from almost anything that they try but
for those who are more sensitive more
reactive or have a more severe imbalance
it's usually 20 to 30 percent from this
20 to 30 from the other thing oops had a
reaction
try another approach 20 to 30 and that's
when you get to that
accumulation of improvement but unless
you have that
overview or that map where you
understand here's the entire process
what happens is you take one step into
what could be a viable process
you don't see a home run improvement and
then it's off to the next
plan or guru or you know new supplement
out there and people get stuck on this
merry-go-round because they don't have a
more overarching structure so your diet
and lifestyle foundation
then probiotics and then we get on to
more of antimicrobial therapy and so on
okay that's really cool um i had a lot
of questions about
candida and i had a lot of issues with
candida until i went to the
carnivore diet and through stool tests
it just wiped it out
but for someone who their main issue
is candida what do you recommend to get
rid of that
it's a great question i'm really glad
you asked it because
i think we fall into really
fallacious territory when we start
thinking about someone's
gut microbiome and their gut health via
the lens of of
one thing i mean sure there are
exceptions to that
maybe histolytica c div but those
exceptions are truly exceptions
the rule is more so how do we cultivate
the healthiest internal environment in
the individual
if you appreciate that we have a
thousand some odd bacteria
a few hundred fungal strains looking at
one of those
you can appreciate it is really missing
the bigger picture
and i know it sounds maybe a little bit
a scientific and hippie dippy
but it's more so a approach of how do we
cultivate
the healthiest garden right and it's a
multifactorial
endeavor the reason why this is so
relevant clinically
is because people end up falling in love
with
candida or sibo and then everything that
they do
is tunnel visioned around that one thing
rather than just saying
well what are the tools that have been
clinically documented
to improve gut health and how can i
apply those tools
to my system that really ends up being
a much more effective endeavor i'll give
you an example some people
who've had candida positive in the past
may actually also tolerate carbs but
they
and i've had patients who they they
don't and they're not sleeping well and
they're tired because of it and their
hair is falling out because they're just
super low carb and they've been to a
carp for a long time
and i'll say to them well why aren't you
eating carbs
well because i had candida positive on a
stool test a year ago
how do you feel when you eat carbs most
of them make me feel great
then why aren't you eating the carbs
and so the other the other part of the
reason why we want to be careful not to
rely too heavily on one lab finding
is some of the more progressive
functional labs
have not been validated and and they are
pretty prone
to false positives and so when you
factor all this together
it's a much more clinically accurate
endeavor to say okay
here are the tools that we know help
people now let's go to work on
personalizing these tools to the
individual
and that should get me that you know 20
percent here 20 there
sure you may had a reaction or two along
the way but the overall
trajectory should be moving someone
toward a healthier gut
and and really the way i look at most of
these
sibo candida blasto
overgrowths imbalances dysbiosis
wherever you want to term it
are more so an outgrowth of an unhealthy
milieu
and we do know that as an example
inflammation in the gut
encourages dysbiosis or it kind of feeds
bad players
and poisons the good players so part of
this is just figuring out how we make
your gut
as healthy as uninflamed as possible
and once we hit that objective that's
usually when everything starts to heal
and we have a healthier growth of the
various organisms in the gut
okay cool that leads me to a whole bunch
of questions but
that's also why you asked me how did you
test the c diff
and originally i tested it through a
natural path and it was sky high and so
i went to my doctor it was like
this would explain some symptoms but is
it true and it was
really true and i had it really badly
good good job on verifying that
yeah yeah i know for sure um i don't
trust anything
um so that kind of segues into are there
like how does somebody start in
identifying do they need first of all do
they need to identify
what's going on given the fact is it
even possible to identify the
exact problems let's start with that yes
great question it's
it's very well worded we can identify
only a fraction of the issues that go on
in the gut so
that is so important because here's a
bottom line fundamental i think people
hopefully will take away
testing promises if we just know what's
going on we can fix you
testing delivers we're not sure what
this means we're not sure if this is
accurate we're not sure what to do
and that's a sad truth but it is
the truth and unfortunately i think the
lab companies
albeit they could be well-intentioned
their
pervasiveness in the education of
clinicians
is skewing the clinicians to not look at
the lab testing
as maybe one fourth of the data needed
to make clinical decisions
but rather they're just focusing on the
lab tests
almost vacuously and not reading the
the symptoms of the individual and then
using it to navigate the
clinically validated therapies i mean it
sounds so simple
but if you can do that you can help
people vastly beyond
what you can do if you do three thousand
dollars worth of lab work and i know it
sounds
like a heretical statement but none of
our case studies
you know they've documented that and um
i try to be as light-handed with this
criticism as i can because i don't want
people to think that
um you know i have any acrimony towards
them other clinicians
but it's really unfortunate when i see a
number of cases come in who've
they have a binder of lab results and i
know that that costs maybe three to five
thousand dollars
and i look at it like this is mostly
crap
and it's just it's really disheartening
to see that so i'd love for that
not to happen as much so yeah lab
testing can be helpful
but you have to really be careful
because there's many labs that are just
way too uh inferential and speculative
okay great um that's that those are the
same conclusions i've
come to i also know that so when i
figured okay my
my problem must be small intestine
related because
the tame out clinic literally did
nothing and i thought that was a good
shot
at fixing some issues it did nothing so
small intestine and
like i don't even know how you can even
test those bacteria we can't even plate
most of them
right once they're out um so you're
saying
there are ways to fix it even if you
don't know what's going on
exactly it's funny you say that because
it's one of the things i write about in
healthy cut healthy you
which is the small intestine right in
the middle of the body right there
there's the stomach you know the
throat in the stomach and then there's
the the colon and the rectum it's hard
to get to it's hard to assess but
it is the most important from a immune
perspective
where 90 of caloric absorption occurs
and where the largest density again of
the immune cells in the entire gut
reside and therefore is most prone to
leaky gut
so unfortunately a lot of the tests
and a lot of the recommendations are
centered around the colon
yet yeah kind of where it's at
clinically not to make it all about you
know one has to be better than the other
but
kind of where it's at clinically is a
small intestine and this is why
the i mean the narrative shifting on the
low fodmap diet over the past five years
i remember being on
the the gut panel at paleo fx roughly
five years ago
and just wanted to pull my hair out
because everyone was kind of
on the bandwagon of oh the microbiome
and feeding your gut bacteria
and lots of fiber and prebiotics i was
just going
like have you not looked at the clinical
literature that when we give people with
ibs with ibd
lots of fiber and lots of prebiotics
sure there's some studies showing
benefit
there's a whole heck of a lot of adverse
reactions documented and
by the way on the other end of the
spectrum this lower carb or
lower fodmap diet sure seems to have a
lot of benefit for those people
which totally contradicts the fiber and
prebiotic enthusiast messaging
that happen because to your point
they're looking at predominantly stool
testing
and what's going on in the clinic
microbiota so there's a huge disconnect
there between
what the clinical literature was showing
and what interesting academic findings
were suggesting
and that has led a lot of people to do
things further for their colon
at really the expense of their small
intestine
that is so nice to hear that is
so good seriously because like that is
that's exactly where i've come to
that's so good to hear and i think that
also explains why the carnivore diet
can kind of work for people or no if the
carnivore diet doesn't work for you if
you've eliminated all these factors
because i have people on so i'm calling
the all beef diet the lion diet i have
people on that diet
and every time they eat they're getting
bloated and they're like what's
happening
it's a gut problem and you can't like
you need
to go to someone to help you but i don't
know where to direct those people i
don't know what else to tell them
because i know the
oral fmt but that's extreme right that
was me trying to avoid going to the
hospital
um but i don't know what to tell these
people who are
getting bloating after they eat even if
all they're eating is
like beef they need to work with a
with a good clinician i mean they can
try the self-help protocol on healthy
gut health you depending on
how severe of a case they are or you
know i see patients remotely and i'm
really happy to say that within
depending on when this errors within a
month or two i'm bringing two additional
doctors on to
the staff and actually if you don't mind
me just you know really quick what
yeah what we're changing with the clinic
is everything we do
from the first point of contact through
the very end is going to be
tracked with a research validated
measure so whether it be a quality of
life assessment that's a research
validated one
or an ibs symptom inventory and we're
going to start really
data mining through our patients and
publishing
um because it's all fine and good and
great helping patients on a one-on-one
basis and i love doing that
but when i look around and all these
patients are coming in and it's like
what has happened to you before you got
to me
it makes me realize not to follow the
clinician i want to be careful not to
not to direct that frustration to them
the education needs to be a lot better
because right now
it's just kind of guru versus guru
bruce's guru
and there's not anyone who's trying to
say well
okay we have all this all this stuff all
these thoughts in the field but
how do we test them and how do we unify
around
the best way to apply these therapeutics
and so
that's what i'm seeing you know
clinically but now
our aim is to really make sure that all
of that is now
in a research validated format publish
that in the journals and then hopefully
really give people something
to unify around so they can really
elevate the standard of care because i
think natural medicine is awesome
um but we could be way better if we got
rid of what didn't work
and then we really focused on what did
oh yeah and people are still people like
anyone who
they learn a whole bunch about one
subject and they think this is it
right and even if they've had their mind
blown oh conventional medicine
medicine isn't all it's cracked up to be
but then you just get into your own lane
and then you
just follow that and you end up with
exactly the same problem
yeah okay that's good to know yeah
there's one other thing here i should
maybe slip in that i
think it's important because um the way
i look at this for a really high level
is on the one hand we have kind of the
gut and the gut microbiota
but then on the other hand we have the
immune system that houses that
microbiota
and yes they have to be in harmony and
so for
some of those really sensitive really
reactive cases
um you do as much as you can with
the gut and supporting maybe leaky gut
with some kind of palliative measures
like glutamine or or what have you
and you go to work and kind of pushing
in probably the microbiota maybe with
probiotics or antimicrobials or
elemental diets
but then sometimes you can only get so
far there and then there's another way
that we can come at this
which is looking at the immune system
because
if you get the microbiota as good as you
can get it
and you're still having a lot of
symptoms then it may more so be the
immune system than it is the microbial
or
it's both but the immune system still
needs more tending to
okay i'm really glad you brought that up
because
so one of my other issues which i have
many of
um was and who knows if this was a false
positive but i was
diagnosed positively for lyme disease
which i don't think was false because
given how severe my arthritis was um
so if i do fix all these problems and i
definitely have gut problems that
still need some fixing um how do you
know if you have an autoimmune disorder
if your immune system just
is screwed up is that something you
think can happen to people like a viral
infection that you're just stuck with
well i mean there's a lot to impact
there because
there's a difference between having a
full-blown autoimmune condition
like let's say rheumatoid arthritis or
hashimoto's thyroiditis
versus potentially just having a
um you know gut associated immune system
your your
galt and your mole and all this that's
just really hyper reactive
um and and maybe one day we'll actually
have a clinical diagnosis for that
almost like when someone has
seasonal allergies maybe there'll be an
equivalent of that for for their gut
um but it's more so
in large part of presumption and sure
there are labs going back to earlier
theme that
offer a whole slew of cytokines but you
know
what's normal what's not normal how do
we you know do anything with that we
don't we don't really know so
more so it's a clinical presumption um
there are some researchers in what's
known as mass
activation syndrome who are really
trying to map out
uh there there's one um
questionnaire published i believe by
dempsey and
afrin who are mass observation
researchers to kind of
symptomatically diagnose mass
conservation syndrome or mcas
the the kind of serum based diagnostic
criteria
it's pretty lofty you're looking at
going to three maybe four different labs
and having to check that there's a
certain like refrigerator refrigeration
and transferring process followed so
it gets pretty in-depth and i think
that's more so
for those who are researching the issue
and trying to pioneer the science
rather than what a clinician does who's
trying to help a patient
that's another i think really important
distinction is sometimes in natural
medicine we're using the test
that the researchers are using because
we're trying to be so progressive not
realizing that even the researchers
don't know how to use these yet and
they're more so just collecting data
trying to understand yet these
clinicians are taking them and making
prescriptive recommendations based upon
them
but there are some ways to maybe
diagnose the immune intolerance or or
overzealousness when i zoom way out the
way i look at this is
we know that lack of breastfeeding or
short-term breastfeeding yeah
not help with development of the immune
system which happens usually within the
first
two to three years of life
so cesarean birth lack of breastfeeding
early antibiotic use
lack of contact with natural
environments all these things
just lead people to have more of this
maladjusted immune system and so
so there's kind of that backdrop and
in these people we can use things like
immunoglobulins
or antihistamines or mass destabilizing
agents
to calm down their immune system and
that for some really sensitive cases
actually finally allows them to start
tolerating other therapeutics or other
foods
okay okay so i was born through a
c-section i was breast-fed but i was hit
with a whole bunch of antibiotics before
the age of one
um so i'm sure that contributed to my
issues
so does that mean though that somebody
who has a maladjusted immune system
can't re-teach their immune system how
to not be maladjusted
my thinking on this is there's
definitely room for improvement yeah and
i think it's really important to
to mention because the last thing i'd
want anyone to think is
well i'm now a prisoner of my past i
don't think that's true at all i think
there's definitely
an ability to improve now some people
will be able to improve more than others
but i think everyone can get to at least
a position where they feel like they
have a reasonable quality of life
okay um and some of these things you
were talking about by
mast cell active something to stabilize
mast cell
response um would that be considered an
immune suppressant
good question and we're getting now into
some areas where i don't have an
incredible
nuanced understanding of the body of
literature but uh with something
let's take an antihistamine right
claritin or benadryl
i i don't believe we can classify that
as an immunosuppressive i mean
it blocks a certain receptor that's part
of the immune response
but that's akin and sometimes what we
end up using
are these over-the-counter
antihistamines
there are also agents like resveratrol
quercetin and vitamin c
that actually or also act to dampen
histamine
or mast cell activation and
then there are amino globulins and
immunoglobulins
they essentially bind to toxins and and
bacterial lps fragments in the gut and
so think of
think of something in the gut that
shouldn't be there kind of like a piece
of glass it's just kind of
making its way through and could neck
and cut and irritate
taking oral supplemental immunoglobulins
kind of glom onto them like
putting wax over a shard of glass and
now that could pass through without
eliciting an immune response and there
has been research done
um one really eloquent study by leonard
weinstein who's also been on the podcast
he's a gastroenterologist and he took a
group of
somewhat recalcitrant and non-responsive
ibs patients who had been through low
fodmap anti-spasmodics with rifaximin
in some cases if they were diarrheal
laxatives and not had optimum response
and then when using immunoglobulins they
reported in that this was an open label
study so
they recorded a 75 response rate when
you factor in placebos probably 40
it was probably more so like a true 30
percent response rate but for
for a 30 response rate in those who are
otherwise
not held by other therapies is pretty
darn impressive and so now one of the
things that we use in the clinic is
immunoglobulins
and that can be one of the few therapies
like vitamin c courses and over the
counter
antihistamines that can help turn the
tide in those patients who are otherwise
really really sensitive
that is so fascinating like when when i
was having these food reactions my
assumption was i was
my gut was a disaster super leaky i was
eating some of these foods and they were
leaking into my body and i was having a
really severe immune response and i did
some research on igg
i don't some sort of igg reaction where
you can actually get
buildups of immunoglobulins
in tissues and that that can cause
problems
but theoretically you understand
this could be totally wrong but
theoretically if you're someone who
ingests something with a super leaky gut
that they shouldn't that their body is
reactive
to theoretically they could take
immunoglobulins and that would help get
rid of it
it can help dampen the immune response
yeah and that's
that's what we we definitely see in some
patients who are really reactive
and then when they're using
immunoglobulins they feel less reactive
and more like they can expand their diet
oh my god i could have used this in
2015. that is so cool
yeah it's that's probably one of the
more exciting
and interesting therapies that i've seen
in the past maybe year or two
that is really cool i'm going to google
that as soon as
we stop this um okay
this has been fascinating so far so one
of the main one question i got asked a
bunch was what do i take to increase
serotonin
but you answered before that you didn't
think there were specific
uh microbes that were responsible for
specific functions yeah
it's real it's really important not to
get uh trapped
into mechanistic thinking because it
just ends up being so fallacious because
you know trying to mechanism your way
out of a problem
it's like trying to navigate
cross-country looking through a
magnifying glass
it's so easy to be misled because the
mechanism
it's too it's too zoomed in and what we
really need to look at
is the clinical outcome data because
this is what tells you
when we take someone with a certain
constellation of symptoms
and we administer therapeutic x y or z
here's the kind of response that we can
see
now we know what's interesting is it
it turns into this almost like volleying
back and forth when we talk about
mechanism because someone can say well
serotonin i heard serotonin so important
for
xyz
it's sure but then you could volley back
with a low fodmap diet has been shown to
increase
serotonin cell density in the guts of
those with ibs and make them more like
healthy controls
so you know if we want to play the the
and i'm not saying you're doing this but
it's just you know people get wrapped up
into this
you can get so lost in there which is
let's just
start to go to work on the things that
will help with your
um pain reception which is what
serotonin will do so if someone's having
abdominal pain or bloating
or your motility um but things like
probiotics also help with both
pain and with motility and ostensibly
something like an immunoglobulin if it
reduces inflammation should also
theoretically lead to an improvement
serotonin um
again the reason why i kind of pick on
this example a little bit
is because i see so many patients who
said well you know now i'm taking acetyl
carnitine and five hcp because
i heard that if you have sibo which i
think i have um
it can be caused by a lack of motility
and those things can help with motility
like
the line of inference becomes so long
that your probability of success
gets right down near zero and it's not
to disparage
the comment but i just try to shift
people into thinking
in a way that will make them more
proximal to the advice that's going to
really be able to help them
okay okay i want to delve into this meat
diet for a minute
um and how i view the diet i'm on
is it's an elemental diet
it gives me everything i need and
there's nothing else
um my husband did it for six months
and he had severe food intolerances he
did it for six months and he added back
in
carbs and very specific carbs and he's
still super
more restricted than he should be but he
felt better when he added
carbs back in um but
after the beef diet he was able to
tolerate more foods than he was before
the beef diet
so um one of the issues i have with it
is i did stool testing however accurate
that is
and i definitely removed a whole bunch
of the carbon consuming bacteria from my
gut because what are they going to eat
and that definitely contributed to the c
diff overgrowth and i do think that
that's a problem
so how would you recommend
people who are on this diet um how would
you recommend them
starting if they were wanting to bury
their diet
well i think the the important thing to
keep in mind is is if you
need to be on this diet i'm assuming
that most the people who are on this
aren't doing it just electively but
rather because they have no i
you have to be so out there to decide to
only eat beef for fun
right yeah i agree um
unless you're paul's held you know and i
love paul but i think he just enjoys it
at this point
yeah i i'm not him i actually do enjoy
salad and apples
yeah yeah um so
um the way i would
think about this first is there's
there's likely some type of imbalance in
the gut
that led to that necessitation yeah and
diet is definitely the foundational
aspect of steering the gut back into a
good direction
but it's also important and this is one
of the things that i lay out
in healthy good health u is it's
important not to try to force
a dietary solution to what might not be
a dietary problem
and so there comes this point at which
if you're having to go more and more
sensitive or restricted with your diet
there's likely something else going on
in the gut and and so
what i would offer people is there's
this world of therapeutics that can help
to correct those imbalances and i was
one of those people
right i was i was doing
everything you know organic
non-processed i was
praying before i ate i thought i was not
too much stress while i was burning
sage doing all this great stuff to try
to put myself in the most healthy
position possible i just didn't realize
there was an
active inflammatory issue so what i'd
recommend to people
is look into a resource to help you
kind of map out okay like here's the
road ahead of the therapeutics that i
can use
in a somewhat linear sequence we can
start with probiotics we can personalize
a probiotic protocol
and hopefully find at least one most
people can at least find
two of the three and then stay on that
for a little while and they should get a
bump there
and and you know work through some of
these available options and what you
should see
is an ability to broaden your diet now
will you be able to eat a whole plate of
raw broccoli
because there's a decent chance that
that may never sit well with you
but between full carnivore and super
high fiber high fodmap
whatever you should be able to get
somewhere you know
in the middle where you can tolerate
some foods
the other thing i'd mention to people is
don't forget about the importance of
rotating the foods in your diet because
if you're coming from a really kind of
porous
gut position and you improve there may
still always be a little bit of sub
optimal
leaky gut present it may be so
subclinical it's not that big of a deal
unless you're eating the same thing day
after day after day after day
and then you could develop a acquired
food intolerance so
plan variety in your diet that's good
from a nutrient perspective anyway
but that can also help you from kind of
slipping back if you know you you earn
back this tolerance but then you're just
using the same thing over and over again
that can prevent you from backsliding so
if you
manage to reintroduce foods or you're on
a limited diet
it's better to rotate foods not
so what is that like can you eat them
all at the same time or do you
section off your limited foods and then
rotate it and i should mention this
hasn't been published this is just
something that i've observed clinically
and there's not a hard fast rule to it i
think it's best for people to try to
look at all the foods they can eat and
try to organize some into monday
some on a tuesday some on a wednesday oh
so quite quick
quick rotations yeah and you don't have
to be
anal about i mean if there's a monday
food that you're not supposed to have
again until thursday but there's a
social event on tuesday i mean
yeah it's not that big of a deal just as
a general principle
try not to be eating the same thing all
the time and you could even do you know
two days in a row and then give yourself
two days off
again there's not a hard exact science
but i think a good way to just
have a loose framing is take all the
food that you eat try to partition them
into day one day two day three
and have a loose rotation that you work
okay
um okay what do you think about this
whole raw milk kick that people are on
i i don't know about the the recent keck
i i've always thought raw milk was
you know probably better than in
pasteurized mount just because of the
bacteria that you'll get from it
and there is some evidence showing that
kids who grew up drinking raw milk
have less i believe it's seasonal
allergy and atopic dermatitis it's a
common kind of
proxy for immune health that's used in
some of the follow-up research on
on children and they're kind of
immunodevelopment so yeah i think
i think you know raw milk as long as
you're sourcing it from a good
spot that doesn't seem to be sketchy i
think it's a pretty good idea
okay um i'm i'm like vocally anti-dairy
which
because of well from the literature i've
read i'm not sure about its effect on
osteoporosis but also
obviously because i'm biased because of
my way overreactive
response to it um well of course it's
contingent upon you tolerating it
absolutely i would say
every time you have it you have a flare
don't eat it um
but i'm pretty dietarily agnostic in
terms of
you know there's gray area foods like
dairy like
grains like legumes and
maybe five years ago i was more well you
really shouldn't have any grains
until i saw enough people that were kind
of like the
inversion of carnivorous meaning they
didn't do well on fat and protein but
they did really good on starchy carbs
and there's definitely that kind of
maybe you would call it like a gut type
or an enterotype out there
and for those people just allowing in
the bring
rice and some other gluten-free grain
product gluten-free although
i'm not going to say gluten is always a
problem but allowing them to bring some
of those back into their diet
like wow i'm sleeping better i gained
that 10 pounds that i was you know
underweight regarding and my hair is not
falling out um
so being in the clinic has really been a
good exercise to make me more
open-minded and we recommend diets now
all the way from carnivore on the one
end to
low flex which is a low fat and fiber
diet and kind of like higher
carb on the other and just as long as
one listens to their body
and doesn't eat garbage processed food i
think there's a
pretty wide menu of foods that are
available
have do you touch uh do you test blood
sugar spikes when you're
looking at these diets or do you just go
based on patient feedback
yeah i i don't uh at some point we might
um but usually we just go based upon
symptoms energy
um it would be interesting though to see
what kind of overlay there is between
food reactive fatigue and blood sugar
my thinking is that the vast majority of
cases it's more of an immune
issue and it may even be you know immune
leads to the blood sugar issue
but it would be kind of curious to look
at how those pan out
yeah or how they kind of like parallel
each other yeah okay
this has been fascinating man this is
this is up there my favorite so far
awesome thank you very yeah this is very
cool
um okay where where can people find you
oh my website's doctor doctoratio.com
d-r-r-u-s
cio.com i mentioned my book a few times
as healthy got healthy you
which was really written to give people
a road map to regain their health and
also
wrapped in a narrative that wasn't
fear-based because like we've talked
about that's one of the things that i
found
is really disheartening when patients
come in afraid of food or feeling like
they have to do
three thousand dollars worth of testing
or feeling like they have to be on
supplements
and sure we use supplements in that book
protocol but they're framed
we're going to use them for a temporary
period of time and then try to find the
minimal effect of those or hopefully
nothing
and then i have a podcast and the clinic
information is all available there
and i'm on instagram here and there
nowhere near as good as
your instagram page but i try no bikini
photos
yeah no no not as yet maybe maybe soon
um but yeah i'm pretty much at the
website you can plug in uh
pretty much everything that i've been
doing okay cool
last question actually um so for people
who come in
because taking pro taking probiotics
seems a lot easier than restricting your
diet
is there anyone you find that can ignore
what they eat
and fix their issues just by taking
probiotics
good question or do you have to look at
diet too
well the individual plays a big role
because
there's a a range of motivations
some people are incredibly motivated and
they want to try to do everything with
food first other people other people you
can tell
they've got limited bandwidth or limited
motivation and so
we may bring in supports earlier for
them
so part of that is just the person that
preferences their motivations
but definitely probiotics
and the other therapies that we've
discussed tend to have this general
trend
of allowing people to be able to broaden
their diet and using dairy as just one
example has been published
probiotics have been shown to reduce
lactose intolerance in those who have
lactose intolerance
and there was even one study that found
in this recently actually
they took a group of patients who are
non-celiac gluten sensitive
and one group went on gluten-free and
the other group went gluten-free and
went on a probiotic
and the plus probiotic group actually
had less
severe symptoms or they had a better
improvement from the combination therapy
rather than the diet alone
so there's definitely a synergy there
but it's kind of a case by case in terms
of you know
when you offer up those supports and and
the way i take this is
if someone wants an easier road i am
more than happy to give it to them i am
not going to beat someone over the head
with a dietary philosophy
if it's going to make their life harder
i think life is hard enough as is
my job is to get them to a point where
they have the energy and the clarity of
mind
to go forward in their life as easily as
possible and then i'm confident when we
get them there
you know they can go forward
successfully so that's why you just
really try to facilitate them down that
path
awesome okay well thank you very much
for coming on i think my audience is
going to find this incredibly
and interesting i certainly did so
thanks well thank you i always you know
i enjoy
talking about this stuff i'm i'm cooped
up in the clinic a lot so it's nice to
be able to share these observations and
insight and there's not
a lot of people who want to go this deep
so it was really enjoyable in mind also
i'm going deep if you take oral fmt
pills
there is nothing there's nowhere i'm not
going like i'm you're at the bottom yeah
yeah yeah i'm at the bottom yeah i hope
[Laughter]
okay thanks again yeah been a pleasure
if you enjoyed this episode please rate
it and leave a review
next week i have andrew doyle the man
behind titania mcgrath on have a good
week
so
you